[Music]
this morning boy have we got a great
summer beach read for you the new
thriller falling
centered around a terrifying premise an
airline pilot is given a choice
crash a commercial jet carrying hundreds
of passengers
or his family back on the ground will be
killed it's written by tj newman a
former flight attendant who worked on
the story while flying at 35
000 feet and it's all the more
impressive because of the struggles
newman dealt with
trying to get falling published
yesterday was the first time you've
flown in more than a year
yeah thank you for making the trip my
pleasure felt great to get back on a
plane
we met tj newman in the city and airport
that serves as the starting
point for her explosively entertaining
first novel
falling so it starts here and my story
starts here too i was based at
lax for 10 years the whole time i flew
so this feels like coming home
see that's a triple seven she's gorgeous
with more americans
finally flying again a book about a
plane that
may or may not crash might not be the
most soothing tonic
just try putting this one down the whole
idea for the story came from
a flight that i was working a red-eye
from los angeles to new york
and i was blocking i'm standing at the
front of the plane
pilots are doing their bathroom break
behind me and i'm i'm looking out
at the passengers cabins dark
and it strikes me that their lives our
lives
are in the hands of the pilot and so
with that much
power and responsibility
how vulnerable does that make a
commercial pilot
in falling after the captain's family is
kidnapped both the crew on the plane
and fbi agents on the ground have to
scramble to save hundreds of lives
the twists and turns that unfold her
ideas newman scribbled down on cocktail
napkins at 35 000
feet she says she went through more than
30 drafts
you got how many rejections
41 41 agent rejections
and 42 was was my one and only yes
you didn't tell anyone you were doing
this i didn't tell anyone i kept it a
secret
yep and you only could tell them after
they started to wonder like what the
hell is tj doing
i'm fairly certain my family assumed i
was leading a double life
which i guess i was but just you know
not in the way that they necessarily
expected look i had come off of several
years in new york pursuing a career in
theater
and it was nothing but failure
i mean just failure after failure after
failure and so when i
left new york i kind of turned a little
bit more
introverted in that way of of risks that
i put out there and that's why i didn't
tell anybody i was writing this book
i wanted to do it for me falling joins a
list of airplane-based thrillers that
first took off
with arthur haley's best-selling 1968
novel
airport you'll kill yourself for nothing
if you explode that bomb
stay where you're from when it was made
into a hit movie in 1970
it spawned a whole new genre of disaster
films
and spoofs passengers certain to die
airline negligence there's a sail at
pennies
none more famous than 1980s airplane can
you fly this plane and land it
surely you can't be serious i am serious
and don't call me shirley
ever since hollywood and the publishing
world have had a long track record of
cashing in on the high anxiety world of
air travel
i have had it with these snakes on this
plane i remember reading a michael
crichton book that was scary incidents
regarding planes and you'd think it
would make people more scared to fly
it actually made me more comfortable
airframe is the book and i love that
book and
that's a response that i've gotten from
from falling as well which
surprised me but i love people have said
you know
i've typically been terrified to fly i'm
a horrible flyer but reading this book i
feel reassured because i didn't know
there were so many options falling will
likely change the way you think next
time you do step on a plane
as newman hammers home hint making sure
your drink is topped off
is not what a flight attendant is there
for it's so nice to have the job viewed
from a more
respectful position now that said the
food and drinks and all that is
is part of it but it's not mainly what
you're there for no
we i mean service is just something we
gladly provide
but you'll almost never see flight
attendants doing their job i hope you
never see us doing our job because our
job is to make sure
if there's a medical emergency we're
handling it
if you're having a heart attack i'm not
going to bring you a diet coke i'm going
to go get the defibrillator
and make sure that you survive flight
attendants are on board for safety and
security
period last year newman took a voluntary
furlough from her flight attendant
duties
recently she quit outright her job
flying is done but it sounds like
writing about planes
is not i flew for 10 years so i don't
think i exhausted all of my
stories and experience in one book so i
might have a
at least a couple more you know surreal
is a word that gets overused and
you know there's there's so many cliches
associated with sort of finding
sudden success in publishing but have
you
have you gotten more comfortable with it
surreal is overused and overused by me i
say it probably multiple times a day but
i don't know
a better word to describe what i'm
feeling this doesn't feel real
i got so used to hearing and accepting
no that it's hard for me to accept that
the yeses are actually happening that
i'm here that this is actually
coming to pass it is surreal
i'm happy for you thank you
we're happy too jeff it's so good it
moves
it it just moves at a great pace it's
it's it's a great b treat it's a great
thriller
i can't wait to see the movie i love her
story because
clearly she saw failure as a path
to success i mean it's just so great
that she
kept moving forward yep after 41
rejections can you imagine her sketching
out the ideas in the cockpit
no it's awesome it's awesome and
thanks for the airplane clip too yes and
snakes on a plane
and air force one and airport
how about that